- The weirdest place you've
ever gotten turned on.
Mine was jury duty.
I don't know what it was about
those fluorescent lights.
Welcome to Three-Way Blind Date,
the dating show where all the
flirting and get to know you
mumbo jumbo is done
entirely through texting
and social media.
I'm Kate, your host, and this is Rita.
- I'm from North Carolina,
but I've been in LA
for the past five years
and I'm hella excited to be here.
I work at UCLA, doing
peer-to-peer coaching.
My passion is just promoting
Lao-Americans in higher ed
and getting us in mainstream media.
- What are you looking for in a person?
- You ain't gotta be passionate about
the same things I'm passionate about,
but you gotta have some type of drive.
- Well, we have three
winners for you today.
- I date often.
I personally don't use dating apps.
I think I've downloaded
them all at one point.
I consider Instagram my dating app.
- I don't date that much,
but I just got out of a relationship,
so that's why I'm here.
- I talk to a lot of girls,
but I definitely don't follow through.
- Here's how the show works.
We are going to ask the guys
some hard hitting questions.
They are going to respond.
We have code names for them.
They are currently Flip, Flop, and Flarp.
They will respond to all
of the questions we ask
on this screen.
We will be able to see.
We will then analyze them and
judge every answer they have
to figure out what type
of person they are,
if it's someone you want to date.
Twist, they are watching
everything we are doing.
- Ah (bleep).
- And you brought your
friend with you today.
- I did.
- Get a little input from a friend.
Who do you see Rita with?
- And is taller.
- (laughs) Oh my god.
- Let's get into it.
First question for the boys.
Take a picture of your
shoes and send it on over.
- Oh, I just sent it to the wrong person.
- (bleep) Not a picture of his shoes.
- Do you have shoe thoughts?
- I like a nice pair of sneakers.
- How do you feel about flip-flops?
- They're okay.
It's not gonna be like a turn-on for me.
- Sneakers turn you on?
- Yeah.
- You got sneakers.
- Okay.
- Alright.
What one do you like the best so far?
- I like the middle one
because they kinda remind
me of my own shoes, kind of.
- Wow, looks like someone's
connecting with Flop.
- What up, Flop, what's going on?
- On an immediate level.
- Flop also has some high rise pants on.
Where's the flood, Flop?
Do you ever like to go
deep on first dates?
Let me rephrase that. (laughs)
Do you like to have deep
conversations on first dates?
- Yeah, why not?
We're saving like 500
hours of emotional labor,
you know what I mean.
- Some of these questions
that we've come up with
are the questions that you'd
want to ask on a first date
but if you were to ask, you
might be considered crazy.
So this next question was a
bit of an ethics question.
You're on a runaway train.
The train is going straight,
and as of right now, the train's
about to kill three people.
But you have the option to pull the lever,
veer off to the side,
and only kill one person.
But that would mean that you
are responsible for
that one person's death.
Do you let the train kill
three people and save yourself
and do you pull the
lever, kill one person,
and be a murderer?
- Either way, you're a bad guy.
- I'm just going for it, full steam ahead.
No, that's messed up, right?
- Flop went ahead and said, pull it.
So he would sacrifice
himself to be a murderer.
Oh boy, we got a real answer from Flip.
I don't usually consider
circumstantial ethics
to be a good metric for morality.
If I had to, I'd have an
easier time killing one person
and living with it although
it would be terrible
and this is why I don't take trains.
- Damn Flip, I appreciate
that thoughtful answer.
What's going on, Flarp?
- I'd derail the train, save one person,
then have Spider-Man pull the
other two away with his webs.
I don't think Flarp got
the question at all.
But I like the world Flarp's living in.
- You're creative.
- What do you think about these answers?
What would you do?
- It depends on the person, right?
- Wait, the type of people
you're going to kill?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Alright guys, she's at
the bar twerking up a storm
and you want to go and strike up a convo.
Opening pickup line.
- I don't know.
Dude, I'm not good at pickup lines.
What should I do?
- What's a good pickup line?
- And Flarp coming in hot
with the pickup lines.
- LOL, you read it.
- Alright, ready?
I noticed you noticing me,
and I wanted to put you on
notice that I noticed more.
- What?
- You want to leave this
place and go to a Cookout?
#NorthCarolina
- Hey, I'm all for it.
Let's go.
It's a restaurant in North Carolina.
- He said, let's go to
Cookout, not to a cookout.
He knew something exactly
about North Carolina.
- Exactly.
Flop, you winning.
North Carolina.
- Is Flop lapping these dudes?
- What you know about that?
- And Flip is shaking in his boots.
- Take too long, I already
gone to the bathroom.
- Flip, in the time it took you
to come up with this opening line,
two or three guys have
been talking to this girl.
Pardon me, ma'am. (laughs)
- What the (bleep)?
- Is that the end? (laughs)
- Pardon me ma'am?
I continue twerking y'all.
But I love Cookout.
- What do you think about Flarp's?
- I appreciate the long pickup line.
- Okay, Flarp, we're
still early in the game.
You can come back from this.
It's not looking great, but
you can turn this around.
Next question, have you ever
sent an unsolicited dick pic?
Be honest.
- Yeah, you better be honest.
- And if you have, send it now.
Just kidding, don't send it.
Could we do a two-parter to this question?
Have you ever sent a solicited dick pic?
How do you feel about dick pics?
- If I didn't ask for it, then
please don't send it to me.
- Have you ever asked for one?
- No.
- Yeah.
- So you don't like dick pics?
- No.
- So far, all we've
gotten from Flip is a no
to the unsolicited and here we go.
A no and then a yeah, he's
sent a solicited dick pic.
Flop said nope to unsolicited
and for solicited he said
seventh grade was a wild time #tbt.
I don't know if a lot
of seventh grade girls
are really asking for
dick pics, call me crazy.
And Flarp is coming up
with an excuse. (laughs)
- Lies.
- Flarp, you beautiful bastard.
We've got Flarp coming in hot with,
he sent a picture of comedian
and civil rights activist
Dick Gregory dies at 84,
the only kind of dick pics I send,
and I'm pretty sure that's Dick Cheney.
I knew that Flarp was a slow burn.
Blaze of glory right now.
He's on a hot streak.
- Okay, yeah, you low-key funny.
- We have this bowl of social clues.
You want to know a little
bit more about their
social presence, maybe learn
what their search history was
or what their first tweet was.
You'll pick from this jar,
and you'll say which person
you want to answer it.
All three don't answer this one,
just who you want to know more about.
- What is Flop's first tweet?
- His first tweet was
a reply to Miley Cyrus.
@MileyCyrus Come to Cape Cod
and blast it off with us.
Seven years ago, tweeting at Miley.
- Okay.
- To blast off.
- Alright.
- With us, who's the us?
- I'm like a not so
much Miley fan now, but.
- Did you like her then?
- I liked her in Hannah
Montana, it was nice.
- Is it safe to say that
this is putting Flop
a little bit in the lead?
Are sparks flying with Flop?
- Yeah, can you see them?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well, who doesn't love an
underdog story, am I right?
Now it's time to turn the tables
and let the guys ask you a few questions.
First up, we got Flip
coming in with a question.
What motivated your
interest in social justice?
- Okay, good question.
I grew up in North Carolina.
My parents are from Laos and Thailand,
and growing up in a
predominantly white community,
my family experienced
hella racism, sexism.
I didn't understand that that wasn't okay.
I got politicized when I
went to UNC Chapel Hill,
started a women of color
empowerment sorority.
It's been amazing and
humbling to come from
that type of past and history.
- Right to the point.
This is from Flop.
- Okay Flop.
- Flop's asking, what
is your favorite part
of living in Los Angeles and why?
- There's so much culture in LA.
You can go to the beach any day,
you can go to any museum.
There's always a lot of education and art.
It's just so beautiful.
You learn so much here.
- You don't even have to leave the state.
You know we can always count on Flarp
to keep it spicy over here
with the hot question ready, here we go.
When was your last one night stand?
- Funny thing, I've actually
never had a one night stand.
(laughs) So you want to be my first one?
- Wow, what's happening?
Now, we're gonna get into
the nitty gritty questions
that you have prepared.
I pass the torch.
- Okay.
- To you.
- Thank you.
- Question number one,
if you could choose a song to twerk to,
what would it be and why?
- You're really into twerking.
- Yeah.
- Do you like a guy who also twerks?
- Doesn't necessarily have to
because I will do the
twerking on behalf of us.
- You twerk for two.
So we got Flarp.
I wouldn't twerk if my
life depended on it,
but I can hit them folks
with a dab of ranch.
I gotta be honest, I'm having a hard time
getting my finger on Flarp's
pulse, to be quite honest.
I can't really.
We got from Flop, this is a no twerk zone,
but if I gotta, we going
Tip Drill by Nelly.
And we got Flip coming in
with London Bridge by Fergie
because whenever I think about twerking,
that song comes to my mind.
- You gotta be open to twerking.
It's okay if you tried
it and didn't like it,
but you were like, no
twerk zone, what, uh-uh.
So you gonna shame me for twerking?
- Uh-oh, Flarp came back with a,
don't try to emasculate us, kissy face.
- Flarp, you ain't winning by saying that.
- Oh my gosh, things are
really heating up here.
- If a friend could
describe you in a hashtag,
what would it be and why?
- Flop came in with the #UpForAnything.
- Okurr. (laughs)
Spontaneous.
- If I can make a guess right now,
I feel like Flip is in fact
having a very hard time
with this question.
If I know anything about Flip.
We got Flip saying #drinkswineintheshower
because sometimes I
drink wine in the shower.
But I cover the bottle
top so no water gets in
because I am also classy.
And then we got Flarp coming
in with #FlarpBiteHeDontBark.
(laughs)
So he's all about action, not
a lot about talking about it.
I would like to point
out Flip is the only one
who answered the question,
both parts of the question.
We've got the excuses
rolling in from Flop.
Didn't hear the and why.
Did you not hear it or were
you not listening, Flop?
- What are three qualities
you admire about yourself?
- Flip, self-reflective,
self-critical, and communicative.
- Mm, okay.
- Flop, we've got energetic,
happy, compassionate.
- Aww.
- Lightning bolt, swirly star, sun.
Flarp, we got my height,
dashing good looks,
and my scent, I love me.
Nobody can do me better than me.
I am nobody, nobody's perfect.
Therefore, I am perfect.
Flarp.
- Y'all.
- Flarp, you know what I
appreciate about Flarp right now?
He is doubling down.
He was like, I don't
see myself winning this.
- Did you surrender already?
- So let me really double down.
We've learned all that
we could possibly learn.
We've talked about twerking,
we've talked about social justice.
How do you feel about Flip?
- I appreciate his thoughtful answers.
What do you think, Sang, in terms of Flip?
- My only concern is
maybe like funny aspects
and just like when we talk and whatnot.
- You want fun as well as informed.
- Fun and informed.
In terms of Flop, I wasn't so sure
if he was ready to go deep with me.
- He was going strong in the beginning.
- Yeah, he was really strong.
I appreciate the North Carolina reference.
That one was pretty dope.
- Then we move on to Flarp.
- You rooted for him. (laughs)
- I was Team Flarp.
- Flarp you had a cheerleader.
I'm still feeling there's
not a thorough understanding
of the type of person
that I see in a partner.
It's hard because you can't
really tell their tone in texts.
- Yeah, and it's hard to
show your true colors.
So if you pick Flip, he'll be serious.
Can he be funny?
You pick Flop, he'll be
funny, can he be serious?
You pick Flarp, was the
whole thing a masquerade
and he's actually a really great listener,
he's just being silly right now?
Because Flarp, he's funny.
- Yeah, you're absolutely right.
- We're gonna bring the guys in.
You're going to see them all.
Do you have the answer in your heart?
- I think I have the answer.
- She has the answer.
I'm excited to see who she chose,
but first let's meet the
ones she didn't choose.
First up, let's see you Flarp.
Come on out.
Flarp with the rose in his mouth.
- It's all good.
- Thank you.
- I just want to say, from the shoes,
it was spiraling all
downhill from the shoes.
My actual name is Brandon Brown.
- Flarp was number one in my book,
but you know what, my book doesn't count.
Let's bring out the runner
up, not the one chosen
but still a contender, let's meet Flop.
- Aw, thank you.
Thank you.
- I flopped.
- You flopped.
- I flopped big time.
- You did.
- You so flopped but.
- It's alright though.
- What's your name?
- Oh, Lichota.
Lichota is my real name, not Flop.
- Thank you Flop.
And that means if you
don't know who it is,
you weren't paying attention.
Bada-bing bada-boom, we've got the winner.
The winner is Flip, come on out.
- Thank you.
- And he voted.
You voted.
- I voted today.
- Congratulations on voting.
- My name is Jeptha Storm.
- Jeptha, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Rita.
- Rita, pleasure.
Oh, we're day drinking.
- You're day drinking.
- Yeah, cheers.
- Cheers.
- That's been our show.
- Follow us on the Gram.
- Maybe you would want to date them.
Slide into their DMs.
They're single, and
they're recently rejected.
- Hey y'all, what's up?
This is Rita coming at
you with some updates.
Me and Jeptha, we didn't go on
a second date unfortunately.
I made a goal to go on
one date a month for this year in 2018.
I am now on date number two.
You saw my interview questions.
If you think you can
tackle those questions,
feel free to slide in those DMs.
Let's connect, let's do something.
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And then your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.